every Thanksgiving sweetheart I have to  go out for a bit today take your meds  your mother's death was a terrible loss  to endure at your age I think you're  afraid because the man who did this was  never caught and maybe that's why you  don't want to leave who's safe here you  can't stay in here forever  [Music]  but California is still missing after a  one research essay on the turn up any  new leads or witnesses  hey where did you get my birthday  present  [Music]  there's blood on this Thanksgiving guy  [Music]  the trailer turn this around on me I  have is awesome do you think I want to  lose you  I'm afraid that's all the time we have  for today